[Applause]
this is unprecedented
in the air and at sea taiwan is
surrounded
when it comes to safeguarding the
interests of the motherland the blood of
heroes always flows in our veins
more than 100 chinese warplanes and 10
warships are taking part in the live
fire drills with missiles launched over
the island into the pacific
and to match the military might
diplomatic sanctions 2.
we are not iraq syria or afghanistan we
will not allow any foreign force to
bully suppress or enslave us whoever
wants to do so will be on a collision
course with the great wall of steel
forged by the 1.4 billion chinese people
the torrent of military activity has
caused havoc in shipping lanes and
flight paths forcing fishermen in taiwan
to stop work
the drill caused some losses one
fisherman said it's squid season now and
some can earn thousands of us dollars
per day
the woman who caused all this is now in
tokyo and sounding defiant they may try
to keep taiwan from visiting or
participating
in other places
but they will not isolate taiwan by
preventing us
to travel there
even as the secretary of state calls the
calm the fact is
the speaker's visit was peaceful
there is no justification
for this extreme
disproportionate
and escalatory military
response those monitoring chinese social
media argue xi jinping was under public
pressure to act they're very strong
sentiment among the chinese population
because they always certainly believe
that tyrants are part of china so they
want the government to react and the
chinese people
don't want
taiwanese people to get hurt of course
not they can see that we're all chinese
family they don't want to harm the
people leaving the island
the hope here is that china's military
drills end as planned on sunday and
diplomatic relations on defense
cross-border crime climate change
gradually recover and even though
privately the white house would rather
none of this had ever happened it has
succeeded in putting taiwan and
questions over its future in the
international spotlight
that may act as a valuable insurance
policy if china's ambitions change joe
pike sky news washington